from the food you put on the grill to
the gas you put in your tank prices for
so many things as you know are soaring
but so far the cost of alcohol has
remained steady in fact americans are
expected to spend an estimated 1.4
billion on beer and wine this weekend
that is slightly less than what they
spent in 2019 before the pandemic but as
scott mcfarland shows us there are new
warnings about a summer of what can be
called booze flation
on his farm in brookville maryland
brewer phil muth grows some of his own
hops
but mooth has noticed something else
more pernicious has taken root inflation
the cost of buying hops barley and grain
has skyrocketed partly from a war that's
interrupted production of those
ingredients in the bread basket of the
world ukraine i had sticker shock this
year when i saw what the bill was u.s
supply chain disruptions have also
slammed their industry and not just for
the ingredients but our most difficult
thing at one time was the cans the
packaging the cans themselves yes
there was a shortage the disruptions
have been so expensive and so severe
they and others scrambled to find a
company in china to ship packaging
supplies for their brews and they warn
this a bubble about to burst in their
industry we haven't yet jacked up our
prices you're absorbing it we're
absorbing it but we're seeing our margin
get
shifted down
so we're having to make decisions right
now about where do we raise prices how
do we raise prices those kinds of things
a risk of booze flation is forming in
many sectors of this remarkably vast
industry that ranges from cans on the
shelf to fine wines distilleries and
tourism-focused wineries and brew puffs
where are you seeing it you're seeing it
in
some of the items that
cannot be bought in bulk
some of the more defined craft items
people are having to pay manufacturers
are having to pay a lot more money to
actually get those products to the shelf
kathy durbin runs the department of
liquor control in montgomery county
maryland says gas prices are adding to
the pressure the heavier products
are going to cost more to ship literally
the heavier products literally yeah i
think the shipping is going to be a big
issue for people until now according to
u.s department of labor statistics beer
wine and spirits have all fared better
in this year of inflation as prices have
increased more gradually than those for
food and groceries partly because of the
heavy competition in the industry all
fighting for shelf space all angling
against and willing to undercut each
other being in business is tough i mean
it's not a walk down you know the easy
street here every business in the
economy not just brewers and
distributors and retailers in the beer
industry pretty much everyone is
struggling with the same supply
constraints
back at the brewery the mooth say they
know trouble is stirring as they try to
figure out how to raise prices without
losing customers and their business i've
seen
our competitors raise prices and
we'll be making some changes
working with our retailers to see what
the tolerances are
i'm afraid this is going to be ongoing i
think we're in this for a while the
question now becomes who in this
industry survives the breweries wineries
and retailers who will supply
amid this inflation because the demand
for alcohol
always remains strong
for cbs saturday morning i'm scott
mcfarland in brookville maryland
see what he did there it'll be
interesting to see when he was saying
that my thought was if you start raising
prices i don't think it's going to be
like gas where it gets lowered again i
think they still stay that way just a
gas so the one thing that could help us
feel better about all this inflation is
now also going to cost more
that is true that is true sorry to tell
you that on your holiday weekend